[Music]
me
That's right. Considering Japan as a whole, it's a shame to think that sushi is a man's job.
It
doesn't matter at all about such a story.
My name is for maps. I work as a sushi chef.
The name of this restaurant is Nadeshiko Sushi. All female sushi chefs, not men.  I mean, it
's about meeting the staff of Mr. Itamae. Old political party All of our staff are about e
67 people.
Nowadays, the sushi restaurant has only male craftsmen, so it's okay to have women.
Beginning
[Music]
Male sushi chef Yes, I've had some changes, but
most people still say that intelligence is a decoration for the staff. I
can't do the details just by standing and holding it.
I think most people feel that it's just looking, isn't it
? Because of
the work of counters, it has long been said that sushi is a sushi business in Japan, so it has a gentle
atmosphere and a
beautiful bright image.  For women who have
sushi, we will set it up in that delicious gorgeous sushi looks more gorgeous. In
such a Japanese society, it is a new field that breaks down the fixed outside.
It doesn't matter if it
's a sushi restaurant with a woman there 2 or a man and a woman holding a woman together, but I
think it's correct and I'm doing my best now
[Music]